[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
barcelona familie und das sind unsere
themen heute
wann kommt die impfpflicht in der
ampelkoalition gibt es debatten wann der
bundestag entscheiden soll und kann
ein touristen ziel als todesfalle auf
einem see in brasilien er schlägt eine
herabstürzende felswand mindestens
sieben menschen
und im slalom zum erfolg - strasser
erkämpft sich beim weltcup in adelboden
einen podestplatz und das olympia ticket
[Musik]
spätestens anfang märz solle die
impfpflicht für alle gelten das hatte
vor sechs wochen der damals noch nicht
gekürte bundeskanzler scholz
vorgeschlagen doch das datum wackelt
möglicherweise auch wegen rechtlicher
fragen währenddessen rollt die omikron
welle weiter die sieben tage incidents
stieg deutlich auf
362 7 und auch die proteste dauern an
patricia wiedemeier
nein zur impfpflicht nein zum impfzwang
es ist das thema der demonstrationen vom
wochenende wie hier in hamburg tausende
von impfgegnern protestieren gegen die
pläne der regierung und der bund länder
runde möglichst zügig eine impfpflicht
einzuführen doch ungeachtet aller
proteste fordert justizminister
buschmann heute in einem
zeitungsinterview zitat der bundestag
sollte schnell entscheiden ob eine
impfpflicht eingeführt wird und wenn ja
für wen die abgeordneten müssen sich
aber auch die zeit für eine sorgfältige
abwägung dieser schwierigen frage nehmen
das sieht der grüne koalitionspartner
genauso wir wollen das jetzt erstmal
ende januar eine orientierungs debatte
eine öffentliche debatte im bundestag
gibt und dass danach gruppenanträge auf
den weg gebracht werden natürlich auch
von unserer seite jetzt liegt das zepter
des handelns hier erstmal parlament der
kommunale spitzenverband der landkreise
fordert die allgemeine impfpflicht
möglichst schnell einzuführen aber die
regierung dürfe das nicht alleine den
abgeordneten überlassen die
bundesregierung angeführt vom kanzler
muss die expertise die in den
ministerien ja vorhandenes mit den
fachleuten jetzt nutzen und selber
gesetzgeberisch einen vorschlag machen
und diesen den abgeordneten schnell zur
entscheidung vorlegen wir haben jetzt
überhaupt keine zeit mehr zu verlieren
in deutschland doch noch sind viele
fragen offen zum beispiel wie eine
impfpflicht überhaupt kontrolliert
werden soll ende januar wird es
voraussichtlich eine erste debatte dazu
geben im bundestag
immer mehr impfgegner radikalisieren
sich liegenden lehnen den dialog ab aber
es gibt auch andere die konkrete fragen
haben unsicher sind ob sie zuzugehen
ihnen ein angebot zu machen das versucht
etwa halberstadt in sachsen-anhalt da
haben heute politiker und ärzte zum
gespräch eingeladen luisa houben waffe
uns dabei hier in halberstadt war heute
jede frage willkommen das wurde dieser
stadt leute geben die sich nicht bieten
lassen
fragen zur notwendigkeit einer
impfpflicht oder wirksamkeit von mast
ärzte und politiker aus halberstadt
ließen sich darauf ein wir können
natürlich nur die antworten geben die
die fachlichen medizinisch-
wissenschaftlich belegt sind und wer das
am ende nun alles nicht glauben will den
kann man glaube ich auch nicht mehr
überzeugen aber alle die die berechtigte
fragen haben kriegen hier gute antworten
man übte sich im gegenseitigen zuhören
und ausreden lassen manch einer der sein
weltbild nicht bestätigt dagegen
kopfschüttelnd
die meisten aber
miteinander sprechen immer gut was ja
heute in der gesellschaft bisschen fehlt
es hätten auf manche fragen etwas
intensiver beantwortet werden können
aber ich finde für den anfang ist das
okay der anlass für das dialog angebot
waren die demos gegen die korona
schutzmaßnahmen wie hier in magdeburg an
vorderster front steht dann die polizei
sich ja im grunde organisiert in einen
dialog zugegeben das ist natürlich sehr
viel bessere weg erreicht aber nicht
alle diejenigen die
gewaltbereit sind oder gewalt anwenden
wollen die werden so eine
dialogveranstaltung befolgen um sie zu
stören in halberstadt lief es heute
friedlich die stadt kündigte an das
format zu wiederholen
seit heute gelten luxemburg und fast 40
weitere länder ganz oder teilweise als
krone hoch risikogebiete insgesamt sind
es damit mehr als 100 welche staaten
genau auf der liste stehen dies und mehr
können sie in unserer zeit erfreute app
nachlesen in der ehemaligen
sowjetrepublik kasachstan sind bei den
schweren unruhen der vergangenen tage
164 menschen getötet worden das
berichtet das staatsfernsehen
2200 menschen wurden demnach verletzt
rund 6000 festgenommen die lage habe
sich mittlerweile beruhigt in der
millionen stadt almaty kamen weitere
russische truppen an der kasachische
präsident hatte sie angefordert und
seinen eigenen sicherheitskräften
befohlen auf demonstranten zu schießen
neben kasachstan blick der westen mit
sorge auf die ukraine heute abend
beginnt ein krisentreffen zwischen
russland und den usa auf neutralem boden
in genf in erster linie geht es um den
aufmarsch russischer truppen an der
grenze zur ukraine
washington hat moskau eindringlich davor
gewarnt in die ex-sowjetrepublik
einzumarschieren und mit massiven
konsequenzen gedroht
fragen der axel sturm in moskau mit
welcher haltung geht russland in die
gespräche mit den usa
ja mit einer sehr selbstbewussten
haltung und mit großen erwartungen zu
kasachstan werde man sich überhaupt
nicht äußern hieß es heute schon in
moskau stattdessen erwartet man in genf
nichts geringeres als vereinbarung über
die künftige sicherheitsarchitektur
europas und das nach den vorstellungen
des kreml also keine nato osterweiterung
die ukraine niemals in der nato und das
westliche militärbündnis müsse waffen
abziehen das alles findet statt vor
einer drohkulisse an der ukrainischen
grenze rund 100 tausend russische
soldaten
der stellvertretende russische
außenminister hat heute gesagt man werde
in diese gespräche nicht mit
ausgestreckter hand gehen sondern mit
klaren aufgaben die zu erledigen sein
dankeschön nach moskau ab sommer das
ein tragisches unglück an einem
beliebten ausflugsort erschüttert
brasilien eine riesige felswand am rande
eines sees brach plötzlich ab und fiel
auf touristenboote mindestens sieben
menschen starben drei werden noch
vermisst der große stausee vormarsch im
rio grande liegt 400 kilometer nördlich
der millionenmetropole sao paulo
alexandra vacano
es ist der moment bevor sich die
felswand von der klippe löst erste
brocken fallen ins wasser vater weg
warnen sie von den hinteren boten nach
vorne pfeifen hofe vater weg doch dann
müssen sie mit ansehen wie der
tonnenschwere fällt auf die boote stürzt
sie unter sich begräbt und eine
flutwelle ausgelöst
die die können rasen panisch auf ihren
booten davon zutiefst geschockt von der
naturgewalt nach dieser tragödie ist die
feuerwehr am abend mit tauchern vor ort
sucht zwischen den trümmern nach
vermissten
die toten und vermissten waren auf dem
boot namens jesus betroffen vom
felssturz wurden insgesamt vier boote
die meisten der verletzten wurden
bereits entlassen und die feuerwehr
bleibt vor ort bis alle geborgen werden
können
der canyon am stausee fuhr nach dass
mehr von mir nachsagen sie hier beliebt
bei touristen wegen des grün leuchtenden
wassers und der spektakulären felswände
vom paradies zum tragischen unglücksort
jetzt die frage nach dem warum heftiger
regen könnte den felsabbruch verursacht
haben und sie wollen klären ob die
ausflugsboote trotz einer wetterwarnung
überhaupt auf dem see hätten sein dürfen
und jetzt wintersportler aber bei
einigen deutschen feuer fangen wir mit
ski alpin an da ist linus strasser im
schweizerischen adelboden aufs podest
gefahren dank eines starken zweiten
slalomlaufs verbesserte er sich noch um
elf ränge auf platz drei und sicherte
sich damit das olympia-ticket für peking
jubel bei linus strasser nach einer
furiosen und zugleich kontrollierten
aufholjagd ich habe es geschafft einfach
den schienen am laufen zeiten keine
riesen fehler zu machen adelboden und
strasser das passt im vergangenen jahr
von platz 12 nach dem ersten lauf auf
zwei vorgefahren diesmal bei schwierigen
bedingungen von 14 auf platz drei
schnellster vor 10.000 zuschauern im
schweizer adelboden der österreicher
johannes strolz mit seinem ersten
weltcup-sieg im jahr schon in der schule
gegangen zwei jahre lang also ich kenne
den namen schon ewig lang hab mir
unglaublich spaß gemacht von jahres auch
mit dem schulfreund aufs podium
olympia-norm geknackt ein perfekter
sonntag für adelboden experte - str
beim bob weltcup in winterberg gab es
einen deutschen doppelerfolg im frauen
zweier laura nolte siegte mit
anschieberin deborah lee die forcam
kalki und bei den männern ließ francesco
friedrich auch heute nichts anbrennen
nach seinem erfolg gestern im 2er
gewinner auch im viererbob mit neuen
bahnrekord seien insgesamt 65 der
weltcupsieg und den gesamtsieg im
diesjährigen weltcup georgien hat er
damit auch vorzeitig herum
bei den nordischen kombinierern in weil
die firma hatte heute vinzenz geiger
allen grund zum feiern der oberstdorfer
ging nach dem springen als zehnter in
die loipe gut einen kilometer vor dem
ziel setzte sich geiger mit einem
furiosen antritt von einer 15 köpfigen
spitzengruppe ab niemand konnte wirklich
folgen der achte weltcup sieg in seiner
karriere johannes rydzek als dritter
vervollständigte den deutschen erfolg
beim 10 kilometer einzeln
das war schon so sport dankeschön fehlt
noch das wetter im
südosten fällt morgen etwas schnee oder
regen sonst ist es freundlich teils auch
stärker bewölkt aber meist trocken die
höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen minus
zwei und plus 6 grad bis freitag ändert
sich daran wenig meist ist es trocken
manchmal sogar länger sonnig viertel vor
zehn das heute journal mit marietta
slomka wir wünschen ihnen einen guten
start in die neue woche sagen tschüss
bis morgen und blicken gespannt nach
berlin zu stark unter labbadia